okay
all right so i'm here with chess weave
also known as denis
borosch eric and we have i feel like
adjusting the pieces
doesn't really no it makes me makes
everything much worse yeah
okay uh we're gonna play a three memphis
game on
the wobbly chessboard and hopefully no
one gets hurt
good luck good luck um it's online
first yeah i think yep okay look
um i love
have fun oh oh no my queen
so online half the time people pre-move
e6
i i remember uh ray robson tricking a
grand master
he's he's known this is where i learned
it from oh it's from him okay
oh man you're you're going for more
trying to be aggressive i don't know if
you're aggressive or tricky
um okay crab is trying to bite
the crab oh
my god i don't know
all right attack
retreat always retreat
these oh they spin here too they spin
but
don't distract me oh okay okay
oh no my pawn okay
all right all right let's let's give up
pawns
it's a fancy move i don't like being
fancy
mmm solid so
hit
wow the pieces have stopped wobbling i
me don't more wobbling
all right um let's
wobble them
okay oh
whoa whoa it's spazzing out
oh my oh no your pawn
even where's one of my pieces let's
check back
or something
oh no i can't move oh can i
oh you've got another one ready i have
two nights
we've got two nights one is more useful
than the other actually both are very
useful
pretty useful they're a bit funky
bishops are useful and let's go here
man i didn't know sadism was rampant
over here oh let's go here
ah well no my pieces
i can't move they can't move
all my pieces have a purpose now yeah
um oh time time
is of essence
oh you don't you don't you want it
actually okay
well if you want it you may get it over
your queen
feels have some fun okay
oh gifts wasn't the gift
gifts are given and received
i i thought man
there's so many things hanging jesus i'm
a good guest
i take whatever you give me
what is this position it's crazy town
take your bishop okay
you take your truck there okay
um i take here
i guess
um it could take
wow
oh you you want something dust i can
tell you want something dastardly
i just wanna not get hurt
oh i know what you oh my god
oh my god
oh my time
i knew i knew i knew something
something's cooking
some oh my no my time as well
no my ah
um let's go
oh oh oh no oh no
where's that oh
oh that was crazy square here oh man
they're waltzing over there the time
scramble in wally chess is
uh it gets very wobbly yeah
but uh the middle part it was
interesting position
yeah this queen size is tricky yeah um
but there's counter tricks yeah so i i
felt that
objectively it looked very promising to
you but it did look
very messy and yeah i
think towards the end um i got
some chances yeah there's weird tactics
yeah
there were really topics on this side
too i just noticed your
evil rook g6 queen h6 made that was
uh i had to retreat and do something
about it
okay anyway hopefully this recording
works if this goes on youtube
subscribe to chesweeb on youtube and on
twitch
and subscribe to eric yeah you can do do
the little subscribe thing
below the video and we'll see you in the
next video
da i forgot to record just kidding
i recorded okay oh my friend